first of all I've seen the whole series
I really want to commend you guys it's
uh it's just fantastic and it's left me
thinking about it you know days after I
I watched it
um
uh before I get started how much of the
series have you guys actually watched I
watched it all I've watched most of it I
think I still have two more episodes to
go curious which of the episodes that
does not involve your characters
um was your favorite like did you have a
favorite storyline that was not your own
uh what would you say favorite there are
certain certainly images that stick in
my mind very powerfully and scenes that
stick in my mind uh particularly
um I I thought that the the trucking
period of time in India was interesting
and I loved the way that episode ended
yeah yeah I think just with hope you
know it gave us a lot of Hope at the end
there after going through that journey
of that of that episode yeah and I I
mean I think there are absolutely uh
there are many portions throughout the
series that are very very uh you know
they they stick with you and
um obviously like the forest fires you
know and floodings and sort of uh the
actual I I just felt very affected
Whenever there was such a physical
effect sort of on a on a location or or
something like that you know I don't
want to give anything away but I just
found it very moving to see you know
even like the images of sort of
um New York you know
basically underwater and things like
that are very very moving and very scary
and sort of uh stuck with me for both of
you
um uh what was it about the material
that said I have to do this or was it
just Scott Burns's name on the script
and you're like I'm in well kind of a
bit of both honestly I felt like we were
in good hands certainly this is the
perfect marriage of material and Maestro
um you know he's so gifted at writing
and he's so concerned and and done his
homework as far as
the science that he's representing on
screen
um so with having said that I was
passionate about the topic it's
something I wish
there was more of in our entertainment
industry
telling the story of the world that we
live in and rather than some other
planet or some other version of the
future that's not contending with things
that we know to be true so for me to
have this nagging sense of concern and
yet
the entertainment industry is not
responding to that that I found very
um gratifying as an artist and then to
watch the end result
I I feel super proud to be part of it
and it sort of came true in in the way
that you hope when you when you sign on
to a show and you don't get to know the
full picture until until you see it
no absolutely and I think that
sky is the per an incredible writer and
the perfect person to sort of lead the
ship of this show
um and by blending an incredibly
delicate balance between
you know science and teaching
um definitely myself and and other
individuals about sort of the minutia of
some of the things that are going on in
global warming and Global change and
sort of the leading sort of efforts and
what they mean and how it's done but
also mixed with you know human emotions
Human Relationships that uh I could we
can all relate to and the humanity that
is pumped through every scene is so
clear
um it's it's every scene is educating
but also you can relate to it on such a
human level and that is so hard to do
and so exciting and as a young actor
getting to work with just such
phenomenal
um writers and directors and and actors
so it was it was very exciting for me
and also it keeps sense of humor which I
I think is key yeah absolutely for me if
no matter
how circumstances are I keep my humor
and that's what I lose my humor then I
know I'm in trouble so
and Scott does too one of the things uh
that I really couldn't believe when I
was watching is just the this the the
ambition of the series and how much
they've used real science to tell a
entertaining story that takes place in
the future
um basically just if you talk a little
bit about the quality of the writing
because it's just so unusual for me for
it to be on this level to you know be
both art and informative it's just a
very uh great marriage well I think you
said it best uh in a way I could just
say I yeah I agree with you
totally it's Scott's brilliant you know
and he has such a sensibility for human
beings and
um he's someone who really does research
and he cares he cares and and so if if
you're going to care that much I'm glad
that he's in control of what's of of the
show because he he's a great Helmsman
and he he sees the the through line so
to have an eye on the Arc of all of
these characters and and interweaving
them and you think well oh and then they
and then we revisit where they are now
and and what their Journey was and how
that impacted the other journey of the
other episode when those characters may
not have been on screen but they come
back later and you see the way they're
interwoven interconnected so
yeah he knows some stuff Mr Burns
land on his feet
um so I love learning about the behind
the scenes the making of shows and
movies is there anything that you think
that soon to be fans of this show will
be surprised or would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of it I
mean as an actor I was surprised by some
of just the sort of tech Marvels that
are happening in this industry now you
know like there are whole scenes where
we're looking at
spaceships I mean we all know about CGI
but until like you like you know you do
a scene you're looking at a wall and
you're like talking to the wall and
they're like no they're gonna put
something there and you're like okay
like I unders I get it but then you
watch the show and you're like I can't
like it's right there's this giant ship
in front of me or like this hologram
that was absolutely not there you know
sort of the the marbles of like movie
making are still so exciting to me you
know
um and
just sort of they had there's this like
there's this like stick with this ball
on it and I don't know what it does but
like half of it is the silver yeah it's
like the half is silver and half is like
dark and they just run in and they just
like move it around I don't know what it
does it centers the world for for the
yeah
for the for the what they're going to
put it yeah and like where everything is
I guess just their ability I always
watch them do that I'm like I don't know
how the heck that like makes like puts
these CGI spaceships but it does and
it's it's really incredible
gotta hats off to those ladies and
gentlemen who are who are uh unsung hero
is necessary you know what I mean like
they make the magic happen that we're
just showing up for magically in our
Park yeah yeah the thing with I know the
ships you're talking about and the
visual effects in this series they're
incredible especially when it's done in
daylight and it looks real
absolutely you know
um before I run out of time with you
guys I definitely want to ask an
individual question for each of you uh
Diane um have you started recording for
inside out too because that's something
that I'm really looking forward to I'm
looking forward to it too the answer is
no not yet I can't wait to get my
scripts and um it's imminent it's coming
up this month I think so you're really
on top of it
I pay attention
right uh and Michael I am a big fan of
Daredevil and Charlie Cox and all those
people and I believe you're part of the
upcoming Daredevil series
um was it talk a little bit about
getting to join the MCU and can you
tease anything about your role I mean
it's incredible it's so so exciting and
daunting and um everyone is so nice and
so talented and um I remember
getting my first text from the producer
I was driving I said welcome to the MCU
and like you see that and it's like
it just like hits you you know like and
like I teared up and it's just like oh
my God like it's it's uh I'm very
grateful and lucky
I believe all I can say about my
character
is that I'm from my characters from
Staten Island
and like that's about it so yeah yeah
you know and and yeah yeah
um but I think people are gonna really
be excited to to be in Hell's Kitchen
and and see sort of
um this this the version of Daredevil
that everyone knows and loves but now a
part of this much bigger world where all
of these other players are now sort of
in play so it's it's exciting Diane
knows how to talk without talking as
well she's done some DC stuff
yeah yeah we're gonna have to have a
versus Marvel exactly
exactly Hey listen um congrats on the
series and thank you for giving me your
time I really do hope a ton of people
watch it oh thank you very much